a lot of people will be reading the fine
print of president Trump's agreement
with Kim jong-un Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham of South Carolina is one
of them he's with us from Washington
senator good morning we've been talking
all morning about this disagreement the
president said and I'm quoting him here
they meaning North Korea have given up a
tremendous amount with this agreement
what are they giving out but nothing
yeah this is an agreement in principle
number one congratulations to president
Trump of bringing this about this is a
historic opportunity to end the Korean
War get North Korea to give up their
weapons and missiles that threaten us in
the world in return for security
guarantees and prosperity I hope it
happens but there is no agreement and
one thing I would tell you John is if
there is an agreement it must come to
Congress for our approval but I'm
confused the president said they gave up
a tremendous amount you say they haven't
given up anything how do we how do we
work our way through that contradiction
well they promise to give up their
nuclear weapons they've done this twice
why should we consider this different I
think they believe President Trump is
different in this regard that if they
don't give up their weapons we're going
to have a military conflict to end their
program
they've got two choices Colome is
security guarantees and economic
incentives to give up your nuclear
program column B is a devastating
conflict militarily which they will lose
president Trump has to convince kim
jungeun he's safer and more prosperous
without nuclear weapons this is a first
step this is a good start but we're a
long way long ways away from a an
agreement so senator on that point as
the North Koreans promise to take steps
toward a complete nuclear
denuclearization the president is before
yeah they've done it multiple times
before and lied about it
right and now we have President Trump
saying that he's going to end joint
us-south Korean military exercises is
that a good idea I don't mind putting
these exercises on hold over the arca
time the exercises won't matter but the
one thing I would object to violently is
withdrawing our forces from South
riah China is trying to play president
Trump through North Korea
China's goal for decades has been to
drive us out of Asia if we withdraw our
forces and that's part of a deal I can't
support the deal that will lead to more
conflict not less our forces in South
Korea are stabilizing for Asia they're
trying to drive us out of Asia China is
and that would be a bad deal so I hope
we don't go down that road well senator
I was just there in May with the 8th
army and you know what their slogan is
because I know you've been there and
you've served it's ready to fight to
knock in there they train all the time
so that they can be ready to defend
themselves and the South Koreans and
their families that live there so what
purpose does it serve ending these
training exercises it gives us breathing
space to get it to get an agreement what
we've done we're not stopping training
we're stopping joint exercises for a
while to give kim jeonggam some
assurance that we're willing to meet him
more than halfway I am willing to do a
lot of things to get them to give up
their nuclear weapons and in their
missile program I'm well you know he can
have a membership at Trump Nationals I
really don't care how generous we are as
long as we don't go too far when it
comes to our troop presence at the end
of the day this is the last best chance
to end this conflict without a war I'm
very open-minded to security agreements
into economic incentives to North Korea
but I am very closed-minded when it
comes to withdrawing our forces
I realize you're making a joke about
giving him a membership international
but this is a man who has more than a
hundred thousand people in gulags in
North Korea listen compared to
concentration camps starting his own
people and torturing them do you think
an invitation to the White House is
appropriate I think the North Korean
nuclear threat is one of the greatest
dangers the world faces the United
States I know who we're dealing with he
kills his own people in large numbers he
killed otto warmbier he's a very bad guy
but I'm willing to deal with him on
one condition that we end this madness
in North Korea he can come to the White
House as long as he gives up his nuclear
program gives up his missile program
Senator Schumer laid out what a good
deal would look like I'm a realist I'm
not trying to bring democracy to North
Korea I'm not trying to unify South
Korea and North Korea I'm trying to help
this president and a conflict between us
in North Korea where they have a nuclear
capability to hit America soon and give
up their nuclear weapons before they
sell them to somebody who would use them
so I'm very open-minded I'm pretty
hawkish on this I mean the john bolton
camp but i'm willing to do a lot in this
conflict but they have to understand if
we don't do it peacefully we're going to
have a military conflict and they will
use it and I hope Democrats will back
the president up regarding the military
option is the last resort yesterday you
tweeted about otto warmbier and you just
mentioned him today the president said
this would not have happened without the
death of border otto warmbier that he
did not die in vain how does that sit
with you do you agree with that well I
hope so I know who we're talking we're
talking about a guy who's just a
complete thug and a killer in North
Korea I have no illusions about who
we're talking to he is not a nice man
but he will do what's best for him in
his inner circle Trump's got to convince
him that you'll be safer and more
prosperous by giving up your nukes than
if you keep them it's all about Kim it's
all about his regime it's not about the
North Korean people I think president
Trump is ready if he had to to use
military force to bring this threat to
noon I hopes
North Korea believes that I hope China
believes it because I believe it and
this is the last best chance to get
peace auto died and I hope he didn't die
in vain but he didn't die he was
murdered he was murdered in the hands of
the North Koreans and I want to look
forward not backward but if you don't
remember what happened to Otto and who
you're dealing with you're making a big
mistake and we're not going to let China
play us we're not going to let China use
North Korea to get us withdraw our
forces from South Korea because that's
very destabilizing that doesn't help
peace that breeds conflict
well senator Graham thank you for
joining us this morning we appreciate it
thank you